I [ __ ] hate American breakfast right
away a big bite of toast my kids like a
flambe over breakfast a wonderful new
fruit in the box cereal I mean how did
we get here how did this become
breakfast in my country and what is
breakfast even all about some people say
it's the most important meal of the day
and others say that it's totally
worthless and you don't even need to eat
breakfast if you don't want to two
pancakes with hot syrup and butter I bet
a lot of you watching don't eat
breakfast in the morning and you know
who else doesn't eat breakfast in the
morning
this guy what do you eat for breakfast
nothing I grew up thinking that
breakfast had to be a certain way but
then in my 20s I started traveling and I
learned that in fact this version of
breakfast is a very narrow very American
version of breakfast once I discovered
non American breakfast I feel like my
eyes were opened to a completely
different approach to the first meal of
the day I want to show you some of those
breakfasts but first let's talk about
breakfast and how American breakfast got
this way for about 22 cents you get as
much nutrition as this bacon and egg
breakfast when there's no time for your
regular breakfast okay before I jump
into all of my opinions about breakfast
let's talk about science for a minute
like facts does breakfast matter is it
actually the most important meal of the
day like I was told my whole life you
can't be your best if you're doing eat a
good breakfast turns out there's data on
this lots of studies but you don't need
to read them all in fact don't read them
all let me give you the twenty second
version turns out the methods in a lot
of these studies are really crummy there
weren't randomized controlled trials
like you know the gold standard for good
science and in a lot of cases they
didn't really study anything useful they
kind of hyper focus on breakfast as it
pertains to weight and in most of these
studies they don't even focus on what
the person is eating for breakfast they
only focus on whether they do or do not
eat breakfast regardless of what they're
actually eating and to add to all of
this a lot of these studies are funded
by corporations
you have a vested interest in making
breakfast seem necessary and healthy so
yeah there's a lot of science on this
but the science does not come to any
useful conclusions and is oftentimes
just poorly conducted what this means is
that there's no real evidence that
breakfast is the most important meal of
the day and there's nothing special or
magic about breakfast that's more of a
marketing myth than anything else had
any really good day's lately like when
the Sun shines brighter and people seem
friendlier and work goes faster days
like that well the really good days
start out good with new Carnation
Instant Breakfast okay wait but there is
a little caveat earnest if you're like
an eight-year-old kid or like a teenager
and you're like in school there actually
is some useful evidence that says that
eating breakfast in the morning is good
for your learning and brain development
so that's the caveat there actually is
evidence there for the rest of us though
if you like breakfast in the morning eat
breakfast in the morning if you're not
into that don't do it okay that's that's
it but unless your kid but I don't know
how many kids are watching okay so
that's the science on this turns out
that I was a person for many years who
thought that I didn't like breakfast
that I didn't need to eat breakfast
growing up in a small town in Oregon I
didn't have a ton of exposure to other
cultures and other things and so my
version of breakfast was this this is
all I knew as breakfast food when we
would eat like eggs and bacon for dinner
we were having breakfast for dinner this
food was inseparable from the
institution of breakfast if you're not
from the United States let me just break
down what American breakfast is and its
story where it came from I'll split it
out into two main categories of
breakfast in the United States one I
call diner breakfasts it kind of looks
like this and the other I will call
cereal which is everything from
pop-tarts to
Froot Loops to granola bars to Carnation
Instant Breakfast it's like the quick
stuff that's in our pantries that we can
just consume before work first let's
talk about diner breakfast there's no
better reference for what diner
breakfast is
United States than the official menu of
I hop which is so inappropriately named
as the International House of Pancakes
welcome to the International House of
Pancakes I at IHOP this American
institution you can start your day with
this the stuffed french toast which
effectively looks like my birthday cake
or you can get really cultured and hop
over to italy for some Nutella crepes or
how about the Belgian waffle combo which
isn't just a waffle but also comes with
bacon and eggs
perhaps you're feeling savory so how
about this breakfast sampler where you
can eat a pig in three different ways
because who just wants to eat bacon when
you could have all three all of this
accompanied by french fries I mean sorry
hashbrowns but why settle for these
meager options when you could go with
the Cinna stack pancakes which come
layered with a luscious cinnamon roll
filling and drizzled with rich cream
cheese icing and topped with you guessed
it with cream icing for breakfast now
here's the thing this diner style
American breakfast is inspired by Europe
American pancakes look a lot like other
sweet flat unleavened breads that are
eaten all over the world and especially
in Europe we just deemed it necessary to
fry it in butter and then put more
butter on top and then drizzle literal
liquid sugar over top and eat it for
breakfast that was the only modification
we made to this wonderful tradition of
European pancakes the idea of eating
pork based cured meats in the morning is
also a European tradition it comes from
like the traditional English breakfast
which is delicious
we just decided to get rid of some
elements from that like the beans and
the tomatoes and the mushrooms who needs
those anyway the American waffle comes
from the beautiful delicious tradition
of the Belgian or Liege waffles which
are served in Desert Storm Belgium
they're delicious the modification we
made was to eat them for breakfast and
then decide to take out the best part
which is the pearl
sugar the crystallized sugar that makes
a Belgian waffle or a Liege waffle
delicious to summarize this diner style
took European traditions turned them
into breakfast and modified them by
making them lower quality bigger
portions and usually slathering them
with cream and maple syrup you can eat
pancakes this cause for all-you-can-eat
silverware get IHOP's all-you-can-eat
pancakes free when you buy any breakfast
combo
I mean icing for breakfast it's just it
just doesn't sound good okay so that's
the diner version of American breakfast
a big important category of what
Americans like to eat for breakfast the
other category
looks like this this is the stuff that's
in our pantries this is the stuff we eat
before we go to work it's quick it's
what I grew up eating as a child let's
call this the cereal category this food
came into our lives and became
widespread because of one main force
industrialization with the birth of
factories and the standardized workday
suddenly you had demand for a consistent
quick convenient food in the morning to
feel you for the day compared with that
you also now had technology to
mass-produce products that would fit
this demand perhaps the best symbol of
this shift towards mass-produced easy
convenient breakfast food is cornflakes
like the Kellogg C corporation which
made corn flakes was a pioneer in making
this breakfast food popular not only
because they were able to mass produce
it and cheaply sell it but also because
they marketed it in this way that made
it feel like the most important thing in
the world
[Music]
but there was a problem over time people
would look at this lousy bowl of
cornflakes and be like who wants to eat
this this is boring but America had a
solution all we needed to do was pump it
full of sugar one gulp of energy jeez I
mean that's that's pretty aggressive
right there Wow yeah that's how I feel
after I eat a pop-tart as well anyway
people started to believe that breakfast
and especially these commodities which
were quickly becoming dessert disguised
as breakfast were the key to a healthy
morning and a good start to the day and
soon I was born into a world a world
where breakfast products and norms were
cemented before me a world where
millions of Americans would wake up in
the morning and consume dessert
disguised as breakfast your muffin is
just a cupcake in disguise that cup of
yogurt might as well be a scoop of ice
cream and then there's the mighty donut
the food that doesn't even pretend to be
breakfast
it's just literal dessert and it's like
shamelessly just like hey I'm dessert
you want to eat me for breakfast and a
lot of people are like yeah I mean I
kind of respect that I'm kind of like if
you're gonna be desert just like
represent yourself and respect they've
done that but wait let me make one thing
clear my issues with this have nothing
to do with nutrition even sugar or
calories or any of that I actually have
a big issue with our obsession with
categorizing food by its numbers and its
constituent parts not into that I don't
really care my problem here is that I
don't like this food I just genuinely do
not want to wake up and consume dessert
for breakfast if you do like this stuff
for breakfast that's awesome I have no
issues with you and I'm not gonna try to
convince you to change that but Cinnamon
Toast Crunch
Lucky Charms and Captain Crunch okay so
a little bit of time has passed and a
few things have changed
number one I got a haircut but number
two I think I'm cracking the code on how
to change my breakfast experience I
spent the past few months thinking a lot
about breakfast and I've started to
introduce different breakfast cultures
into my morning routine that have really
changed my world I'm not going to share
all this with you now because this video
would be like 30 minutes long but I have
been filming all of this and it has been
a really interesting journey to invite
different breakfast cultures into my
world if enough people are interested
and you leave comments somewhere I will
share it and make a video about what
breakfast looks like for me these days
spoiler alert there's no icing I still
have my occasional bowl of Lucky Charms
which is a delicious cereal and the
occasional pancake with my kids it's
great stuff I mean I'm not above that
food it's just not what I want to eat
every morning so anyway I'll show that
if you're interested lastly I want to
tell you about today's sponsor which is
Skillshare which is a place where I have
learned a lot of my video skills but
they also have cooking tutorials I
discovered they have a course on their
about how to make the perfect grilled
cheese sandwich which by the way is an
amazing breakfast and it's one of
thousands that Skillshare has of all
different types of topics whether it is
animation and video which is are the
courses I've taken or entrepreneurship
business photography design like
basically everything Skillshare is
incredibly cheap and for you it could be
completely free for two months you could
have access to all of these tutorials
for free if you go to the link in my
description click that link and help
support this channel but more
importantly it kicks off your journey of
learning something new for free for two
months that's like two two months it's
like 60 days of zero money playing
around with this really awesome resource
on the internet and then after that it's
like less than ten bucks a month if you
do the annual subscription which is just
ridiculously cheap for what you're
getting
Thank You skills here for supporting
this channel and letting me make these
videos and thank you all for watching I
will see you in the next one two eggs
four slices of bacon or sausage links
hash browns toast juice to hand juice
just $1.99